[Music]
welcome to film tonight this episode I'm
joined by two of the funniest folks
alive the stars of night school Kevin
Hart and Tiffany Haddish
thank you so much for stopping by since
your new film is about going back to
school Tiffany I'm wondering what do you
think you'd say to your 18 year old self
always be true to who you are because
you are a unicorn that's great that's
great what about for you Kevin what do
you think you'd say to 18 year old Kevin
Hart for one I would say don't drink too
much at Super Bowl party man what would
I say I don't know I don't know there's
a lot that I was saying yeah you know 80
or old me well we actually have a little
surprise for you joining us right now
here in studio Kevin meet your actual 18
year old cell man come on out Dan you
know how 3d printers work no why are you
telling me this is not Kevin okay
are you blind look at me we're faith are
you serious
were you sawed in half by magician I
don't forgot to reattach it I don't know
cut me in half this is a full beef
burger okay this is a big burger you
like a slider
come on a couple inches Tiffani be an
inch or two you know what it was coffee
really I was drinking back-to-back cups
of coffee
that's what stunning me a little bit but
other than that this is exactly what it
was yeah I need a DNA test cuz this is
not sure it proves me watch this hey
young keV dude it do the tongue thing
needs to do I think we're missing the
point here what do you think dad used to
do that all the time my god I think I'm
pregnant I had a gland problem
I used to sweat and I used to do this
because I would start stinking so I took
my shirts off is it tease me look at
kept all out of shape you need to get in
the gym keV man thank God I finally did
this is beautiful that is not beautiful
I feel like we've got an off topic this
is an amazing opportunity Kevin what
else do you want to say to your 18 year
old self you know look you gonna go
through a situation where you find out
you got
bs which is irritable bowel syndrome I
didn't find out so I was older there's
uh groups that you can talk to about it
and when you come together and realize
it as a people that other people are
suffering from hey man hey Tiffani I'm
talking to young me why I'm talking to
young me is this gonna up the
space-time continuum listen we should be
fine okay well then I'm gonna have me
some fun it's all funny game so you
realize I had unbelievable gas every
five minutes Peppa Peppa Peppa like a
goddamn Rhoda pellets I would just leave
yes milk that's all the time we have on
film tonight see you next time
yes ma'am yeah hey Josh this is a messed
up it's just not it's just not good
[Music]
you know what else I used to get in
trouble for I used to wear women's belts
that was a big thing
you